[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de Parlement
Hebdo on va revoir la semaine sous le
regard de notre invité et on accueille
cette semaine Xavier bonjour bonjour
vous êtes sénateur des Hauts-de-Seine
vice-président du groupe RDP au Sénat le
groupe de la majorité présidentielle et
je précise que vous êtes également
candidat à votre réélection aux
prochaines sénatoriales en septembre
pillage incendie destruction
affrontement les violences urbaines
embrasse le pays depuis la mort de Naël
17 ans tué lors d'un contrôle de police
à Nanterre pour un refus d'obtempérer
quelle réponse face au chaos et au
malaise des quartiers on en parle dans
un instant avec notre invité
[Musique]
cette semaine l'Assemblée nationale a
dit oui au partage de la valeur le texte
issu d'un accord entre syndicat et
patronat et l'argile les possibilités de
prime mais aussi d'intéressement au sein
des entreprises une partie de la gauche
regrette la faible portée du projet de
loi
[Musique]
et puis la loi de programmation
Méditerranée par les sénateurs le texte
donne un budget de 413 milliards d'euros
armés pour faire face aux nouvelles
menaces le président de la République
espère son adoption définitive avant le
14 juillet
la mort du jeuneel a fait vivement
réagir cette semaine les parlementaires
la gauche demande un changement de la
loi de 2017 qui facilite l'usage des
armes par les policiers de son côté
l'exécutif tente d'apaiser la situation
face aux pays qui s'embrassent le récit
de cette semaine par Aurélien Romano
après une seconde nuit de violence le
président de la République a été amené à
réagir jeudi matin depuis la cellule de
crise du ministère de l'Intérieur les
dernières heures ont été marquées par
des scènes de violence contre
commissariat mais aussi des écoles des
mairies et donc au Fonds contre les
institutions et la République et
celle-ci sont absolument
injustifiable Emmanuel Macron avait la
veille voulu faire baisser la pression
en faisant part de son émotion face au
décès à jugés inacceptables et
inexcusable de Naël au Sénat tous les
groupes de gauche pointent
l'augmentation de l'usage des armes à
feu par les policiers depuis 2017 date
de l'entrée en vigueur d'une loi de
Bernard Cazeneuve assouplissant les
règles d'engagement par les forces de
l'ordre en cas de refus d'obtempérer
cette loi est testament trop laxiste
elle a manifestement permis le
développement d'un sentiment d'impunité
qui hier a conduit à un drame monsieur
le ministre si vous voulez que le calme
revienne et nous l’appelons de nos vœux
il est temps de revenir sur cette loi le
ministre de l'Intérieur qualifie cette
demande de récupération politique et
vous avez monsieur le sénateur profité
c'est affreux de ce terrible drame pour
appeler votre position la loi qui avait
prise de président Hollande et le
Premier ministre Cazeneuve dans des
temps différents puisque c'était des
temps je le rappelle d'attentat
terroriste pour la première ministre les
images vidéos de l'intervention ne
semblent pas respecter le cadre de la
loi les images choquantes diffusées hier
montre une intervention qui ne semble
manifestement pas conforme aux règles
d'engagement de nos forces de l'ordre la
droite sénatoriale se montre très
prudente sur ce sujet ou
traditionnellement les LR se place du
côté des forces de l'ordre je vois bien
que et notamment à gauche à l'extrême
gauche surtout on tente de passer
du procès d'un policier au procès de
toute la police ou bien d'un certain
nombre de modalités de doctrine d'emploi
des âmes je pense qu'on en est pas là le
rassemblement national a jugé lui que
c'est à la justice de répondre à cette
affaire et non au gouvernement de la
commenter Xavier la France a connu
plusieurs nuits de violence des scènes
de chaos des scènes de pillage est-ce
que vous craignez que ces violences ne
durent plusieurs semaines comme c'était
le cas avec les émeutes de 2005 bien sûr
qu'on le craint et je pense qu'il faut
séparer les deux événements il y a à la
fois ce drame de mercredi matin avec ce
jeune Naël et on est tous parents mardi
matin pardon on est tous on est tous
parents on est tous citoyens moi c'est
en plus mon département ma
circonscription celle de Nanterre et
donc effectivement on ne peut qu'être
choqué par ce par cette mort du jeune
Naël mais qui doit
apnée à une réponse claire de la justice
et la justice s'est saisi très
rapidement je vous rappelle quand même
que il le policier a été mis en examen
pour violence pour meurtre pour
assassinat pardon non pas ça pour
homicide voilà je cherchais le mot
homicide volontaire ce qui est quand
même très rare il a été incarcéré tout
de suite après la garde à vue à la
demande d'ailleurs de ministre de
l'Intérieur il a été suspendu
administrativement donc on voit que la
justice fait son œuvre qu'elle va vite
et c'est tant mieux et donc il y a cette
partie qu'il faut à la fois respecter le
deuil de la famille respecter le temps
de la justice et il faut apporter des
réponses claires et puis il y a d'autres
événements qui sont là pas directement
liés je trouve à cet événement qui sont
effectivement les violences urbaines et
la dégradation aujourd'hui de du bien
public et on a l'impression je vais hors
de contrôle que la
situationnelle et c'est ça le problème
c'est à dire que lorsque
lorsqu'on s'attaque et moi je parle
principalement de mon département
lorsqu'on s'attaque dans les
Hauts-de-Seine à des écoles à des
collèges au Mémorial de la déportation
qu'on a qu'ils ont dégradé quand on
brûle des commerces quand on brûle le
tribunal de proximité d'Asnières quand
on brûle des tramways qui permettent aux
salariés de se rendre sur leur lieu de
travail et bien effectivement il y a des
réponses à apporter et on ne peut pas
tolérer cela et moi je salue aujourd'hui
la position des élus de des
Hauts-de-Seine je vous salue d'ailleurs
la position du maire de Nanterre qui
démarre d'histoire a appelé dans un
communiqué de presse au calme et à
l'apaisement et que la justice devait
passer mais que la justice ce n'était
pas la rue et ce n'était pas la
vengeance je salue également la décision
du maire de Clamart je disais bergers
qui a mis en place ce couvre-feu pour
permettre de d'apaiser aussi la
situation dans sa ville les élus locaux
sont mobilisés mais est-ce que la
réponse à cette situation est bien la
décision d'imposer un état d'urgence
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas s'il y
aura un état d'urgence je ne sais pas si
nous devons le faire moi je vois
effectivement les décisions qui sont
prises à l'échelle locale les couvre-feu
donc c'est restrictions de liberté dans
un temps donné qui sont la possibilité
qui sont données au maire de le faire je
pense que c'est la bonne solution pour
apaiser la situation et permettre aux
forces de l'ordre de reprendre on va
dire le contrôle et permettre que les
biens publics ne soient pas non plus
dégradés parce que il n'y aurait rien de
pire que au-delà du matériel nous
arrivions à un deuxième décès lors de
ces émeutes ça passe aussi peut-être par
une reprise en main du pays comme le
demande certains avec l'affirmation
d'une de plus de fermeté mais dans la
réponse je pense que je pense qu'il n'y
a pas de doute sur la fermeté à la fois
du gouvernement de l'exécutif du
président de la République je pense que
à la fois il y a eu des mots
d'apaisement du ministre de l'intérieur
de la première ministre du président de
la République qui ont eu des mots très
clairs sur l'apaisement et sur l'appel
au et sur la nécessité de respecter
aussi le deuil de la famille et une
fermeté avec 40 000 policiers et
gendarmes qui sont mobilisés partout sur
le territoire pour justement lutter
contre ces violences et ses dégradations
je pense qu'il n'y a pas la main de
tremble pas alors en tout cas c'est
violence urbaines mettant lumière un
malaise social de la Genèse dans ces
quartiers on va écouter sur ce point
votre collègue parlementaire des
Hauts-de-Seine la députée écologiste
Sabrina sebahi les mots ne suffisent
plus aujourd'hui parce que ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui ça fait des années
qu'on le dénonce cette relation police
population s'est discriminations
permanente cette relation avec les
quartiers les villes populaires les
contrôleurs faciès à sa répétition le
fait que c'est certaines catégories de
personnes qui subissent des refus
d'obtempérer où on leur tire dessus
c'est pas tout le monde donc tout ça en
fait en réalité ça fait des années qu'on
dénonce et ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui
c'est le résultat d'année d'inaction
d'injustice et de deux poids de mesure
vous avez à Covelli est-ce qu'il y a eu
de l'inaction de la part des pouvoirs
publics sur cette question des banlieues
et notamment pour Emmanuel Macron qui
avait enterré on le rappelle le plan de
Jean-Louis Berlo sur les banlieues cette
situation c'est aussi son échec ça va
pas été enterré le plan de Jean-Louis
Borloo a été pris en partie ça ne s'est
pas appelé le plan Bordeaux mais en
l'occurrence il y a un certain nombre de
mesures sur la politique de la ville je
vous rappelle que c'est sous le
gouvernement de d'Emmanuel Macron qu'on
a doublé les crédits de l'enrup pour me
permettre justement la rénovation
urbaine de nouveaux quartiers pour avoir
des immeubles sociaux qui soient à
échelle humaine et ne plus avoir ces
barres qui est des années 70 qui
pouvaient aussi créer une un sentiment
de de délaissement on va dire des
pouvoirs publics on a remis des services
publics aussi dans les quartiers alors
bien sûr il y a beaucoup à faire encore
moi je suis issu d'un quartier populaire
je sais très bien les la nécessité
aujourd'hui de continuer à investir de
remettre des services publics mais si je
suis pas sûr aujourd'hui que c'est en
les brûlant ces services publics que
nous allons pouvoir en remettre donc moi
j'appelle la députée de Nanterre qui qui
mérite de d'être arrivé dans notre
circonscription récemment je l'invite à
effectivement nous soutenir et à
soutenir comme le maire de Nanterre le
fait le réinvestissement dans les
services publics le soutien et surtout
de l'appel à l'apaisement et au calme
alors justement l'apaisement au calme
mais tout le monde n'appelle pas
forcément au calme il y a eu le député
insoumis du Nord David Guiraud qui a dit
qu'il n'applait pas au calme qu'il
appelle à la justice qu'est-ce que vous
lui répondez je trouve que s'il est
responsable c'est inconscient
inconscient dans ces en fait quel est le
but de la France insoumise c'est d'avoir
le chaos dans notre pays c'est d'avoir
d'autres morts dû à ses émeutes le fait
que on demande la justice c'est pas
incompatible avec le fait de demander le
calme et l'apaisement chef de lui sur le
fromage ce n'est pas enfin encore une
fois depuis le début la France insoumise
continue et instrumentalisent c'est les
événements qui peut avoir dans notre
pays et ça depuis 2017 vous savez quand
il parlait du fait de tout ce qui
n'obtiendrait pas dans les urnes il
obtiendrait par la rue c'est aussi une
façon d'attiser d'appeler à
l'insurrection systématique de dans
notre pays c'est aussi un moyen
d'attiser et je ne mets pas sur le même
plan tous les élus de la nups je mets et
qu'effectivement ceux de LFI d'ailleurs
parfois ceux qui habitent dans les beaux
quartiers parisiens et ceux qui ne sont
pas directement confrontés à la
situation des émeutes et de la violence
parce que encore une fois ce ceux qui
habitent dans les quartiers populaires
qui subissent sont nos commerçants se
sont nos agents municipaux qui eux
subissent les violences et les
dégradations alors on l'a vu dans le
sujet d'Aurélien Romano la mort du
jeuneel a ré-ouvert le débat sur les
interventions policières Xavier est-ce
qu'il faut changer la loi de 2017 qui
facilitait l'usage des armes par les
policiers en cas de refus d'obtempérer
et je le précise de légitime défense moi
pense que il n'y a pas de tabou on doit
pas avoir de totem et de tabous sur la
question de l'utilisation des armes et
sur la fait de revoir une loi qui a
effectivement faite sous le gouvernement
Hollande pour répondre à une nécessité
notamment pour répondre sur les actes
terroristes et sur la violence qui qui
en découlait donc faisons en sorte de ce
réunir le Parlement et là pour ça pour
débattre sur ces sujets là mais je ne
suis pas mais moi je ce que je ne veux
pas ce que je ne veux pas c'est qu'on
puisse légiférer et prendre des
décisions sur l'urgence et sur l'émotion
encore une fois ce n'est pas parce que
nous allons changer là dans la
demi-heure ou dans le week-end une
législation que ça apaisera la situation
faisons en sorte de nous de nous mettre
autour d'une table que le Parlement
puisse travailler sur cette question là
moi je n'ai pas de de doctrine sur sur
ce là je n'ai pas de tabou à revoir une
loi qui pourrait éventuellement évoluer
mais encore une fois ne les chiffons pas
sur l'émotion il faudra une commission
une enquête parlementaire sur le refus
d'obtempérer dans et bien ces
interventions policières c'est ce que
dit pourquoi pas mais pourquoi pas le
Parlement est tout à fait apte à faire
des enquêtes et c'est notre rôle aussi
de contrôler du gouvernement et des
différentes institutions donc c'est le
rôle d'un parlementaire de pouvoir
contrôler l'action l'action publique
donc moi je ne suis pas contre une
enquête parlementaire mais encore une
fois ne faisons pas de la récupération
je pense que aujourd'hui nous sommes
dans une période où nous devons appeler
au calme et à l'apaisement et une
réforme de la police en profondeur comme
le demande par exemple Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ce serait une bonne chose pour
vous ou pas ça veut dire quoi une
réforme en profondeur de la police moi
je ne sais pas ce que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
dit quand si effectivement Jean-Luc
Mélenchon si on suit ce qu'il disait il
voulait désarmer la police que certains
insoumis disent que la police tue
effectivement moi je ne suis pas
aujourd'hui sur cette ligne là si
aujourd'hui nous n'avions pas aussi nos
policiers et nos gendarmes qui protègent
les équipements publics qui protège les
crèches les écoles les collèges les
mairies qu'est-ce qui se passerait ce
serait le chaos est-ce que c'est ça
aujourd'hui que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
cherche moi c'est pas ce que je cherche
donc faisons en sorte d'avoir un cadre
il y a un cadre légal qui est clair qui
est défini ce qui s'est passé avec le
jeune ailes à priori d'après les images
qui sont profondément choquantes cela
sort du cadre qui est défini par la loi
la justice le confirmera je le souhaite
en tout cas je souhaite qu'il y ait une
réponse de la justice rapide mais encore
une fois ce n'est pas remettre en cause
je suis là où je ne suis pas d'accord
c'est que il y a une faute grave très
grave d'un policier mais c'est pas la
police qui est remise en cause c'est pas
la police qui a fait une qui fait des
violences c'est ce policier
effectivement qui a tué le jeune à elle
alors on va poursuivre cette émission
avec un autre sujet celui de la du
partage de la valeur en entreprise les
députés ont voté l'extension des
dispositifs de primes et d'intéressement
le projet de loi a été largement voté
malgré les réserves sur les bancs de la
gauche et les Amanda
l'accord entre les partenaires sociaux
transposés dans la loi objectif étendre
les dispositifs de partage de la valeur
aux entreprises entre 11 et 49 salariés
elles devront mettre en place un
mécanisme participation intéressement
aux primes si leur bénéfice Netflix
fiscal est supérieur à 1% de leur
chiffre d'affaires trois années
consécutives si la France est la
deuxième nation d'Europe en ce qui
concerne le partage de la valeur nous
avons encore des marges d'amélioration à
la matière nous pouvons être bien
classés au sein des nations européennes
mais ce n'est pas une raison pour ne pas
chercher à faire mieux à faire plus et à
faire encore davantage pour la
rémunération et les compléments de
rémunération de salariés en un sens
quand la richesse est créée qu'elle soit
encore mieux distribuées au sein de ceux
qui ont contribué à la créer
c'est tout le sens de la corps signé par
les partenaires sociaux et le sens de ce
projet de loi mais pendant les débats la
gauche a fait entendre une autre
revendication la hausse des salaires
seuls et unique manière pourtant de
partager la valeur créée par les
salariés par tous les salariés des
entreprises dans un contexte d'inflation
féroce ou le salaire réel diminue vous
avez montré même si cela n'était
malheureusement pas approuvé de quel
côté vous vous situez évidemment celui
du patronat et du capital les insoumis
et les communistes ont voté contre le
projet de loi les écologistes se sont
abstenus alors que les socialistes ont
voté pour de l'autre côté de l'hémicycle
les républicains et leur rassemblement
national ont aussi soutenu le texte
112 voix pour 27 contre et 8 abstentions
oui merci alors vous avez dit certains
estiment que c'est primes vont remplacer
les hausses de salaire dans les
entreprises le gouvernement assure que
non mais vous admettez que ce risque
existe non je ne dis pas ça je pense
effectivement que déjà c'était un accord
entre les partenaires sociaux entre le
patronat et les syndicats représentatifs
de des salariés ça date du mois de
février les derniers et donc on ne peut
pas à la fois nous reprocher de ne pas
écouter les partenaires sociaux et en
même temps lorsqu'on retransmet qu'on
transpose dans la loi à la virgule près
les l'accord qui a été fait entre les
partenaires sociaux nous le reprochez
également donc ça c'était une demande
forte des partenaires ensuite quand le
partage de la valeur c'est quoi c'est
lorsque l'entreprise crée de la richesse
a des résultats positifs fait des
bénéfices et ben tout le monde en
participe tout le monde participe à
cette répartition de la richesse avant
de pouvoir redistribuer la richesse il
faut la créer et c'est le tout le sens
en fait de ce partage de la valeur et
donc moi je trouve que c'est un bon
accord qui n'a rien à voir avec
l'augmentation des salaires
l'augmentation des salaires c'est un
autre sujet où les partenaires sociaux
d'ailleurs sont en train de travailler
aussi dessus mais le partage de la
valeur c'est avant tout le partage de la
richesse de l'entreprise quand
l'entreprise crée de la richesse c'est
normal qu'on puisse la répartir mais
quand même dans la réponse de la MA ont
été présidentielle à cette question du
pouvoir d'achat est-ce qu'il n'y a pas
une préférence qui est donnée à la prime
temporaire par rapport à une hausse de
salaire pérenne c'est pas le cas la
prime temporaire c'est ce qu'on a fait
voter avec la prime Macron c'est toutes
ces dispositifs qui permettent de
supprimer des charges pour permettre aux
entreprises de donner un coup de pouce
aux salariés ça n'a rien à voir avec le
partage de la valeur qui est encore une
fois et sur l'intéressement sur la
capacité de l'entreprise qui fait des
bénéfices à faire partager cette
richesse avec l'ensemble de ces salariés
et ça c'est encore une fois c'était
aussi une demande des partenaires
sociaux alors il y a un débat qui est
revenu dans l'hémicycle celui sur les
super profits est-ce que pour vous il
est plus juste qu'une partie de ces
super profits reviennent aussi aux
consommateurs que nous sommes tous via
par exemple une taxe sur les super
profits comme le demande certains mais
nous avons fait cette taxe soit super
profit au niveau des énergéticiens donc
moi je n'ai pas de tabou sur ça je
préfère je préfère par contre
pardonnez-moi je préfère par contre que
cet argent aille directement dans la
poche des salariés que nous puissions
baisser les prix et c'est tout ce que
nous menons aujourd'hui avec Bruno Le
Maire sur la question de l'inflation et
sur les les prix sur les produits plutôt
que d'avoir d'encaisser des recettes une
taxe supplémentaire qui se nouerait dans
un budget d'État moi je préfère qu'on
répartisse la richesse des entreprises
au niveau des salariés à ceux qui
travaillent ce qui créent la richesse
les ouvriers les salariés de ces
entreprises plutôt que de créer une
énième taxe qui se noie dans le budget
de l'État ce type de texte ça peut
permettre de tourner la page de la
réforme des retraites et du
mécontentement social je sais pas si ça
tournera moi je le souhaite je pense
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement il y a des
sujets importants dans notre pays et
qu'il faut pouvoir avancer il faut
pouvoir continuer à réformer pour
améliorer aussi le quotidien de nos
concitoyens et donc cette question de
partager la valeur en fait partie et moi
je salue la décision de de d'origine du
socle et du gouvernement de pouvoir
retrans enfin transposer ce texte
directement dans la loi alors Xavier
maintenant direction le Sénat puisque
les sénateurs ont adopter jeudi le
projet de loi de programmation militaire
en pleine guerre en Ukraine ce texte
prévoit une hausse historique du budget
de nos armées 413 milliards d'euros de
crédit entre 2024 et 2030 les sénateurs
sont d'accord avec l'ambition du
gouvernement mais on souhaitait que ce
budget supplémentaire soit débloqué plus
vite que ne le prévoit le gouvernement
on va évoquer on va écouter sur ce point
le président du groupe les républicains
au Sénat Bruno Retailleau 413 milliards
d'euros ça n'est pas rien c'est un vrai
effort simplement nous voulons
dans cet article lever un doute un doute
qui est lié à une incertitude un doute
qui est lié aussi à une facilité
l'incertitude ce sont les crédits qui ne
sont pas budgétés
ça n'est pas nous qui l'avons pointé
c'est le Haut conseil ou finances
publiques et notre trajectoire a un
mérite c'est que il matérialise c'est un
lieu de matérialise concrétise les 7,4
milliards qui ne sont pas
et le doute lié évidemment au reste
c'est à dire à la facilité c'est que
l'essentiel
de l'effort est reporté après 2027 et
nous on veut que ça soit une progression
qui soit linéaire parce que sinon c'est
le même effort les mêmes marches que la
LPM actuelle
parce que c'est maintenant la guerre
c'est maintenant qu'on doit faire un
effort parce que c'est maintenant
l'inflation que l'euro d'aujourd'hui n'a
pas la même valeur il vaut plus que
l'euro de demain voilà ce que je voulais
vous dire Xavier la majorité de droits
de sénatoriales souhaite que cet effort
budgétaire pour nos armées se fasse
maintenant comme on l'a entendu ça
paraît logique on est en pleine guerre
en Ukraine mais je pense que la majorité
LR a bien compris que nous avions mis
déjà des moyens supplémentaires
notamment pour répondre à la question de
la guerre en Europe la guerre en Ukraine
et que cette loi de programmation
militaire de 413 milliards enfin je veux
dire c'est pas une pacotille c'est quand
même ce qui va faire nous permettre
d'avoir en plus d'être la première force
en nombre d'hommes de en nombre d'hommes
on a la plus grande force armée d'Europe
en nombre d'hommes nous allons avoir
aussi le plus gros budget européen sur
l'armée donc c'est une vraie ambition
portée par le ministre le corps nu par
le Président de la République et donc
effectivement c'est un vrai progrès je
pense effectivement que c'était aussi
une attente forte de nos armées en
termes de matériel en termes de réponse
aussi sur une revalorisation de nos
pensions pour
nos militaires pour la protection aussi
de leur famille l'accompagnement donc
tout ça ce sont des éléments qui sont
importants j'ai vu que les LR avait
proposé 7 milliards supplémentaires de
dépenses supplémentaires notamment sur
l'aspect matériel moi je vois aussi
qu'il y a globalement un consensus sur
sur cette loi de programmation en
militaire et que en commission mixte
paritaire nous aboutirons à
je pense que nous aurons un accord et je
ne doute pas que que cette loi de
programmation militaire sera validée
définitivement avant le 14 juillet comme
le souhaite Emmanuel Macron une petite
question cette loi pèse 413 milliards
d'euros et prévoit un saut technologique
pour les armées comme le dit le ministre
de de la défense et notamment la
construction d'un nouveau porte-avions
néanmoins quand on regarde le niveau de
la dette française qui paie qui atteint
plus de 3000
milliards d'euros est-ce que vous pouvez
dire que la France a encore tout
simplement les moyens de sa défense ce
qu'elle ne voit pas un peu grand avec
une dette pareil je pense que la
situation géopolitique est
internationale et y compris aux portes
de l'Europe nous démontre que nous
n'avons pas le choix et nous devons à la
fois nous protéger à la fois avoir cette
force de dissuasion qui est importante
dans notre pays et qui est historique
nous on a encore les moyens de notre
défense y compris
les moyens de notre défense de notre
défense et d'ailleurs je je note que
de dépenses sociales parce que c'est
bien aussi de de comparer nos dépenses
sociales c'est 30% du PIB notre force
militaire et notre dissuasion de force
de dissuasion militaire c'est 1,9% de
notre PIB donc on voit bien que nous
continuons à avoir une politique sociale
très importante dans notre pays et moi
je souhaite que nous la maintenions et
que nous l'accentions il est aussi
important que nous puissions protéger
les intérêts français à l'extérieur mais
aussi à l'intérieur et que notre nous
ayons une armée conséquente et dotée et
surtout qui soit respecté dans dans ces
conditions et donc c'est une demande
forte de nos militaire c'est une demande
aussi de nos territoires et la situation
internationale nous pousse en tout cas
avoir ses doigts de programmation
militaire ambitieuse c'est important
d'investir davantage dans notre
dissuasion nucléaire cette dissuasion
c'est la réponse dans le contexte
géopolitique inquiétant qu'on connaît la
dissuasion nucléaire la question de
l'innovation vous en avez parlé sur la
question des drones sur la question de
l'espace c'est tout ça ce sont des
éléments importants pour la protection
des intérêts français et donc oui oui
c'est tout à fait important une dernière
question en quelques mots et ce qui est
la France doit rester dans le
commandement militaire de l'OTAN je le
souhaite je souhaite il faut que nous
restions cette décision a été importante
et il faut que nous continuions à être
présent la France est un grand pays
historiquement nous faisons partie du
concert des nations et donc nous avons
besoin de de continuer à
œuvrer dans ce sens alors on arrive au
terme de cette émission juste un petit
coup d'œil avant de se quitter au menu
parlementaire de la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
et mardi les sénateurs commenceront le
débat dans l'hémicycle autour du projet
loi qui est censé réguler l'espace
numérique et qui prévoit de nouvelles
obligations pour les opérateurs du
secteur jeudi la commission d'enquête du
Sénat sur l'affaire du fond Marianne
publiera son rapport tout comme la
commission d'enquête des sénateurs sur
le réseau social chinois Tik Tok et sa
stratégie d'influence à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est la réforme de la justice
qui est au programme de la session
extraordinaire qui s'ouvre ce lundi 3
juillet le texte a déjà été voté par le
Sénat et puis à suivre mardi une
audition de Bruno Le Maire qui sera
auditionnée sur la relance du de la
filière nucléaire et c'est la fin de
cette émission merci beaucoup Xavier
d'avoir été notre invité cette semaine
et merci à tous de l'avoir suivi
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine à très
bientôt ciao ciao
[Musique]